[Musique]
le mur de berlin est le plus puissant
symbole de la division est ouest qui
s'amorce
après la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale l'allemagne est scindé en deux
parties dont l'une sous l'occupation
soviétique de 1949 à 1961 de 3 à 4
millions d'allemands vont fuir vers
l'ouest en passant par berlin
c'est pour cette raison que le mur sera
construit dans la nuit du 12 au 13 août
en quelques jours les barrière de fils
barbelés sont remplacés par ceux qui va
devenir le mur de berlin
d'une longueur de 43 km et d'une hauteur
de quatre mètres
ce mur de la honte comme on l'appelle
coupe les rues en deux les pâtés
d'immeubles même les maisons des
miradors sont placés tous les 250 mètres
les soldats reçoivent l'ordre de tirer
sur les fugitifs s'ils ne peuvent pas
les arrêter autrement près de 5000
personnes ont réussi à franchir le mur
140 y ont perdu la vie en 1989 la
libéralisation de certains pays comme la
hongrie ouvre une brèche des milliers
d'allemands de l'est en profite pour
passer à l'ouest
au soir du 9 novembre n'annonce de
l'ouverture des frontières provoquent un
exode instantanée et la chute du mur de
berlin